Hallöchen ihr Lieben! Wir machen heute leckere türkische Pide Schiffchen.
Ich glaube jeder, der sie mal probiert hat, liebt sie einfach!
Und ich zeige euch jetzt, wie das ganz easy Zuhause funktioniert.
Ich mach jetzt hier erstmal einen Hefeteig und die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen unten in der..?
[Hamza] Infobox!
[Kiki] Infobox! So!
Ich hab jetzt hier mein Mehl, da werde ich mir eine - Ah, halt stopp!
Ich hab ja so einen kleinen Lifehack! Ich mach's ja immer so, dass ich mir vom Mehl
- damit man sich halt später nicht ärgert, dass es dann zu trocken wird -
so ungefähr 50g beiseite nehme und das tue ich dann gleich nach und nach mit dazu.
So, jetzt bilde ich eine Mulde und gebe da Wasser rein.
Das sollte lauwarm sein. Nicht über 40° C, sonst stirbt die Hefe ab.
Und das Rezept funktioniert übrigens auch mit trockener Hefe. Schreibe ich euch dann aber unten in die Infobox, was ihr da  nehmen müsst.
So, einmal das lauwarme Wasser  hinein geben, frische Hefe hinein bröseln
und dann noch Zucker dazugeben.
[Hamza] Ich hab vergessen, die Kamera anzumachen Kiki! Ist das schlimm?
[Kiki] Oh, naja..
[Kiki] Verzeiht ihr's dem Hamza?
[Hamza] Also ich hab hier noch ne zweite Kamera aber ich hab vergessen, die anzumachen!
[Hamza] Aber ich glaub man hat alles verstanden!
[Kiki] Ach, ja klar!
Ich geb jetzt auf jeden Fall den Zucker dazu wie grad schon gesagt, dann verrühre ich das kurz
und dann lassen wir das 5min stehen damit die Hefe sich, ja so ein bisschen..
damit die so ein bisschen anfangen kann, zu arbeiten.
So, jetzt geht's weiter!
Ich knete heute alles mit den Händen, das geht natürlich auch mit der Küchenmaschine!
Ich gebe jetzt hier Olivenöl mit rein,
Joghurt, da könnt ihr z.B. 3,5%-igen nehmen, oder ich hab heute sogar 10%-igen! Also immer das, was ihr grad da habt.
Und dann gebe ich auch noch Salz mit dazu, super wichtig!
Und dann einfach anfangen, zu kneten
und das Mehl, das wir vorhin beiseite gelegt haben, nach und nach mit dazu geben.
Das Ergebnis muss halt so ein elastischer Teig sein, also so ein schön fester Teig.
So, ich hab den Teig jetzt nochmal mit den Händen auf der Arbeitsfläche geknetet.
Ich finde dann bekommt man auch ein schönes Gefühl dafür,
wann der wirklich fertig ist oder wie lange er noch geknetet werden muss.
Wenn er gerade so nicht mehr an den Händen klebt, dann ist er fertig
und dann könnt ihr ihn zu einer Kugel rollen, ganz grob.
Und jetzt müssen wir ihn 45min lang gehen lassen, ihr könnt ihn auch 1h lang gehen lassen wenn ihr Zeit habt.
Am besten an einem warmen Ort ohne Durchzug. Das ist grad bei offenen Küchen so wie bei mir halt immer super schwierig,
dann sehe ich zu, dass ich das in den Backofen stelle, der aus ist, dann habe ich keinen Durchzug.
Ich gebe jetzt aber noch ein bisschen Öl in die Schüssel und benetze auch die Teigkugel mit Öl
und dann geht's weiter!
Ich hab den Teig übrigens gestern Nacht schon vorbereitet.
Ihr könnt das auch super easy Zuhause machen, gerne am Vortag.
Also einfach nur alles zusammenkneten (dann müsst ihr auch kein lauwarmes Wasser nehmen sondern könnt ganz normales kaltes nehmen)
und im Kühlschrank gehen lassen.
Also nicht auf Zimmertemperatur, sonst fängt der Hefeteig an, zu stinken und dann könnt ihr ihn nicht mehr gebrauchen.
Ich hab's einfach in den Kühlschrank gegeben, da ist er schön aufgegangen, weil ich mir jetzt einfach für den Dreh ein bisschen Zeit sparen wollte.
Und jetzt auf der Arbeitsfläche durch - also in 4 gleichmäßige Teile teilen
und anschließend zu Kugeln rollen und unter etwas Mehl zugedeckt nochmal 15min entspannen lassen.
Während der Teig jetzt nochmal ein bisschen ausruht, wollte ich euch die 2 Füllungen zeigen für da heutige Video.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch weitere Füllungen machen, wie z.B. Spinat- oder Kartoffelfüllung.
Und falls ihr Interesse daran habt, dass ich euch die auch mal zeige,
dann schreibt mir doch gerne einen Kommentar und bei der Gelegenheit: Hinterlasst meinem Kanal auf jeden Fall ein Abo!
Also hört mal, ne? Allerhöchste Eisenbahn wenn ihr das noch nicht gemacht habt!
[Hamza] Aber Kartoffeln hab ich richtig Bock!
[Kiki] Ja, Kartoffeln hätte ich auch Lust.
Aber heute habe ich mir gedacht, mache ich auch 2 andere leckere Füllungen, nämlich mit Käse und die andere mit Hackfleisch.
[Hamza] Ich hab's: Du kannst Gözleme machen mit Kartoffeln!
[Kiki] Jaa, geile Idee! Okay, wir machen Gözleme, Hamza hat's jetzt einfach so entschieden!
[Kiki] Mit was wollt ihr dann Gözleme sehen? Mit Kartoffeln und und und..
[Hamza] Kartoffeln auf jeden Fall!
Okay, ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal die Feta Füllung sage ich mal, obwohl's ja eher so ein Topping ist.
Dafür nehmt ihr euch einfach Fetakäse oder Schafskäse und dann einfach nur zerdrücken mit der Gabel.
Da gebe ich dann gleich fein gehackte Petersilie mit rein und noch ein bisschen Gouda.
Da könnt ihr auch Kaşar Käse nehmen, Emmentaler, was ihr möchtet!
So, für unsere Hackfleischfüllung nehme ich jetzt auch die Petersilie, die ich gerade ja schon für die andere Füllung fein gehackt habe
und gebe die schon mal direkt dazu.
Dann reibe ich da auch gleich 'ne Zwiebel mit hinein. Ihr könnt auch auf die Zwiebel verzichten
wenn ihr kein Zwiebel Fan seid aber ich find das macht nochmal einen richtig leckeren Geschmack.
Und vor allem wenn man sie fein reibt, dann verbindet sich das noch besser mit der Hack - mit der Hackfleischmasse, genau.
Zum Hackfleisch gebe ich dann noch Paprikamark, Salz, außerdem Kreuzkümmel und Pul Biber,
das sind Paprikaflocken und ganz typisch für die türkische Küche.
Nachdem ihr das dann geknetet habt, ist die Masse auch schon fertig.
Also ich hab wirklich nur 'ne Minute geknetet, einfach mit den bloßen Händen.
Und jetzt nehme ich mir meinen ausgeruhten und entspannten Teig
und werde ihn auf meiner Arbeitsfläche mit ein bisschen Mehl sehr, sehr dünn, allerdings oval ausrollen.
So, den Teig habe ich jetzt auf 2mm runtergerollt, also richtig schön flach.
Und jetzt nehme ich mir ein bisschen Öl, ihr könnt da auch gerne Olivenöl nehmen,
und werde mein Blech damit so ein bisschen einfetten.
Das Besondere an dem Blech ist: Durch die spezielle Lochung kommt ja Luft von unten direkt an den Teig
dann habt ihr das wie im türkischen Restaurant, also richtig schön knusprig unten!
[Hamza] Ich find's auch cool, dass du kein Gadget benutzt, also kein Backpinsel oder sowas!
Nee, ich benutze keinen Backpinsel. Einfach mit der Hand, die sind ja sauber.
So, und jetzt gebe ich das drauf. Bei mir passen 2 auf ein Blech, deswegen rolle ich den zweiten gleich schon direkt hinterher.
Und ich glaube ich mach jetzt auch eine mit Käsefüllung, ein Pide
und den anderen mache ich direkt mit Hackfleisch und dann kommt's ab in den Ofen.
Jetzt haben wir hier ein bisschen am Rand freigelassen und jetzt müssen wir einfach die Seiten einklappen und oben so ein bisschen zwirbeln.
Ich hab jetzt noch ein Ei mit Milch verquirlt und die Seiten damit bestrichen
damit die auch richtig schön goldbraun werden nach dem Backen.
Den Ofen habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt. Das ist auch super wichtig, dass der Ofen richtig auf Temperatur ist,
nämlich auf 220° C Ober- und Unterhitze.
Und dann backe ich jetzt meine Pide Schiffe goldbraun und mache dann in der Zwischenzeit die nächsten.
Ihr könnt übrigens auch Suçuk draufgeben oder was ihr auch machen könnt - den Tipp möchte ich euch nicht vorenthalten -
Einfach ein Ei draufschlagen.
Nicht jetzt schon, sondern ungefähr 2min vor Ende der Backzeit.
Also einfach das Ei reinschlagen und dann zu Ende backen, nur so als Tipp nebenbei!
Und das war's auch schon mit dem heutigen Rezept!
Ich hoffe, dass ihr die Pide Schiffchen fleißig nachmacht, die schmecken unglaublich lecker!
Vor allem weil die unten so knusprig sind und innen diese leckere Füllung!
Macht's unbedingt nach!
Wir haben heute leider keinen Taste Test für euch weil wir am Fasten sind und.. ja - es ist noch hell draußen!
[Hamza] Aber ihr könnt den Taste Test auf Instagram sehen.
Genau, Hamza zeigt euch auf Instagram den Taste Test!
Folgt uns auf Instagram, ich schreibe euch unsere Links unten in die Infobox
und dann freue ich mich, wenn ihr bei meinem nächsten Rezept auch wieder dabei seid.
Tschüss, eure Kiki! Und der Hamza!